it's frustrating it's inconvenient and
it's bad for the environment and there's
simply no reason for it this is the
United States Camaro for God's sake this
is who we are this is not this is not
what we should be doing
hey what's reaction Texas Senator Ted
Cruz Senator first question do you agree
with me that my premise here they can't
run on anything that they're successful
at anything that they've done to improve
the country so I say they've got three
things January 6 hating Donald Trump
they got the usual Playbook Republicans
of racist and sexist and xenophobic and
January 6th and that's about it an
abortion
Sean you're exactly right if you look at
the issues that that are racking the
country that are hurting Americans
across the country you have number one
inflation the Democrats have no plan for
inflation other than to make it worse to
spend trillions more and drive inflation
up even more gas prices they have no
plan to reduce gas prices other than to
make it worse by hammering American oil
and gas production crime they have no
plan to reduce crime other than to make
it worse by continuing to support
radical leftist DA's and leftists who
try to undermine defund or abolish the
police and illegal immigration they have
no plan to stop they don't want to stop
their plan is more illegal immigration
more chaos at the border and and so
their only political strategy which you
can see their cronies in the corporate
media leaning in on is distraction they
want to scream Donald Trump all day long
because there is nothing on planet Earth
they hate more than Donald J Trump they
want to unleash corrupt partisans at the
department of just Justice in the FBI to
go after Donald Trump to try to distract
people and they want to send Joe Biden
up to give the most divisive and hateful
speech we have seen a president give in
our lifetimes calling half of the
country fascists they're hoping to scare
people into showing up and voting for an
agenda that's failing and what's amazing
they don't they don't plan to change
they don't promise change they promise
more of the same more of the same
disastrous policy agenda all right so in
2016 the media mob they played a big
part in the election they peddled
Hillary Clinton's bought and paid for
dirty Russian dossier in 2020 they
pushed the narrative that Hunter Biden's
laptop was nothing but Russian
disinformation it was anything but now
the question is you're a debate champ at
Harvard uh Alan dershowitz once said on
this program you were one of the
smartest students he ever had the honor
of teaching so you have an ability to
debate and you're really good at it
others do not not have the same skills
that you do when the media comes after
any Republican candidate or Conservative
candidate and they go after these three
issues can you please teach some of your
colleagues because I've watched some of
them and they need help please teach
them the art of pivoting away from what
they want to talk about which is every
day Donald Trump everyday abortion and
move on to the issues that are impacting
this country
Sean you are preaching to the choir we
need to be positive affirmative with our
message we need to be happy Warriors the
angrier they get the more we should
laugh and be joyful because their agenda
doesn't work and and you're right the
Democrats and the Stooges in the
corporate media they just want to repeat
the attacks and it's a real mistake when
you see Republicans that will have a
long discussion about this particular
attacker that that particular attack
rather than just going on affirmatively
our Solutions look what do people want
people want jobs with good wages people
want their families to be safe and
secure people want their rights
protected that that is a common sense
agenda that the overwhelming majority of
Americans agree with and so the
corporate media doesn't want to talk
about it at all it's our responsibility
to lean in and explain listen was
America better a couple of years ago
when we had the lowest unemployment rate
in 50 years or is it better now now when
people are hurting across this country
was America better when gas was two
dollars a gallon or four dollars a
gallon under Joe Biden was America
better when we had the lowest rate of
illegal immigration in 45 years which is
what it was the last year the Trump
presidency or is America better now with
utter chaos and 4.2 million people
coming across the border illegally it
ain't complicated everybody knows there
isn't a Democrat out there that can
defend this policy failure and so they
count on the media just to change the
topic we need to not fall for it we need
to instead urge the American people if
you don't like the path we're on we can
change the path of November and Sean
mark my words the media are trying to
convince Americans suddenly the
Democrats are surging in November what
utter garbage Republicans are going to
win the house and we're going to win the
Senate and I can tell you between now
and election day I am on the road
non-stop campaigning for Senate
candidates and house candidates because
we're going to come in with big
majorities to start the work of turning
the country around the senator I hope
you're right and are you better off than
you were since Joe Biden's been
president on based on any measure you
can make I I don't see we're better off
in any way uh shape matter informed Now
Kevin McCarthy I was there I was the
emcee the night that Newt Gingrich
became speaker of the house he had a
contract with America it's 28 years ago
and I'm getting old Senator and anyway
but he's coming out with commitments for
America I don't know why and I'm not
just I'm not being critical of Mitch
McConnell here as of now he has not
embraced the idea of the Senate doing it
as well I would like to see the Senate
do it if Mitch doesn't want to do it
then I assume the individual candidates
can sign on to it there's something
about a pledge a promise in writing that
I think sends a powerful message that
you mean it and you're going to get it
done and if you don't you're going to be
held accountable
listen I agree and I will say there's a
division of thought in Washington uh
there's some people who have been in
Washington a long time that think the
way you win elections is just you don't
stand for anything you don't engage on
issues I think that's exactly backwards
I think the way you win elections is you
draw a line in the sand I think the way
you win elections is you say these are
the stakes and here's what I will do
when we win and when you're clear and
when you follow through on your promises
that's what makes people show up to vote
and and so every candidate out there
that is campaigning on specific clear
promises that they intend to follow
through I salute them but I'll tell you
once we win you and I both know that
that the battle is not over on November
8th that once we have a majority we need
to do something with the majority and so
that's why I'm fighting not just to win
in November but to elect strong
conservatives that will then have the
guts and let me tell you one of the
things that we ought to commit to do
every single Republican ought to say we
will not vote to fund these 87
000 new IRS agents we're not going to
fund Biden's Army to harass Americans
and we're going to take that money and
put it on our Southern border to secure
our border that ought to be a promise
every Republican Gets behind now and
that we follow through on when we have
the majorities next year Senator Ted
Cruz Texas thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else